hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll last week we
talked about geometry and topology these
were clearly mathematical ideas but I
think that most people know these are
ideas that have a big role in physics so
today since we did math last week we're
gonna do math again okay
we're gonna talk about symmetry now
symmetry is a quintessentially physics
topic symmetry is at the heart of a lot
of modern physics but the way that we
describe symmetries is gonna involve
some math and that's basically what
today's big idea is how we go about
actually describing symmetries if you've
ever heard of the standard model of
particle physics you may have been told
that it's based on a symmetry group su 3
cross su 2 cross u 1 so at the end of
this maybe not today but at least today
or next week we're going to understand
exactly what that means to say that the
symmetry group of the Standard Model of
particle physics is su 3 cross su 2
cross u 1 those are those letters those
symbols su 3 etc correspond to internal
symmetries so they're actually
transformations they're basically
generalized rotations of different
fields in the standard model of particle
physics so the quantum field theory will
come into play we also have what are
called external symmetries I guess are
they called external symmetries they're
not internal symmetries space-time
symmetries is what I'm talking about
we know that for example you can
translate where you are in space you can
rotate where you are you can change your
reference frame and special relativity
all of these are also symmetries so this
is why symmetry is so crucial in modern
physics but what is it what do we mean
this so this is the kind of thing that
mathematicians do right they take an
idea that you have and you think you
understand it at some intuitive level
and they try to formalize it make it
precise and then talk about its
properties in general circumstances far
abstracted from any specific application
then the physicists come back in and say
I bet I can find an application for that
so that's what goes on with the study of
symmetry so what do we mean let me let's
get into what we mean by symmetries by
starting with some examples just draw
some shapes on the on the iPad here and
you can
for yourself how symmetric they are so
here is a completely non symmetric
little blob there you go
I don't see any symmetries there at all
and look I've been practicing for you
folks don't say I never did anything for
you I've been learning new things on
notability here watch this triangle but
boom it becomes all nice now I'm gonna
make an equitable triangle there you go
hopefully it's neck lateral triangle
okay that seems to have more symmetry
than the blob like somehow there's some
regularity there that we would like to
be able to understand better likewise we
could draw a square there you go
hopefully that's really a square not
just a rectangle but again some symmetry
there and what if we could also draw a
circle this is going to be harder to
draw but I can do it here we go there's
a circle okay four different shapes and
I've arranged them in what I will argue
is order of increasing symmetry there's
more symmetry as you go from left to
right and that kind of has an intuitive
sense the circle in particular looks
extremely symmetric right it looks the
same from every different angle but this
is what helps us turn these vague ideas
into something formal and manipulatable
at the level of equations and theories
of physics we want to know exactly what
we mean when we say there's more
symmetries in the circle than the square
more symmetries in the square than the
triangle and we kind of already gave it
away the idea that you can look at the
circle from any different angle is a
reflection of the fact that there's some
symmetry there the symmetry is a way of
saying that there's a transformation we
can do to some object to some system
that leaves the essential features of
the system invariant
that's what symmetry is not sure if
that's the technical definition well no
sorry I am sure that it's not the
technical definition but a symmetry is a
set of transformations which means in
math you terms a set of maps from the
thing to itself a set of ways you can
manipulate the thing back to itself
transformations
that leave let's just say leave the
system whatever it is invariant what we
mean is leave whatever we count as the
important features of the system
invariant so to make that a little bit
more specific
think about the triangle we can clearly
rotate the triangle by a hundred and
twenty degrees right
if you rotate it by 120 it goes back to
the same triangle you can rotate it
again another 120 240 then you rotated a
third time and you get 360 degrees it's
back to where we started
so let's actually make that explicit ok
so here's another triangle we're gonna
that was not a very a collateral
triangle but I'll try to fix it there we
go
pretty close here's our original
triangle I'm gonna duplicate it a couple
times and here's my original triangle
again duplicate good put it over here
and this will all make sense why I'm
doing it in this particular way and I'm
gonna label the vertices okay ABC I can
label them any way the labels are
completely arbitrary it's that's up to
me I just want to keep track of what I
do to the triangle because the whole
point of the symmetry is I'm gonna do
something it makes it look the same so a
B and C are not labels that we
physically stick onto the triangle
they're just to remember what we've done
to it okay so what I mean by this is we
could for example rotate clockwise 120
degrees so that's one third of the way
around the circle I'm gonna call that
operation r plus the notation will make
more sense in a second so what our plus
means rotate 120 degrees so I get C a B
okay that's what I mean by that
particular rotation so you see that if I
had rotated by 90 degrees I would have
gotten the triangle off at some angle 90
degrees whereas if I rotate by 120
degrees I get exactly back to where I
started if I were really fancy about it
watch what I could do I could take the
triangle and I could rotate it and this
is why I'm not doing it in real time
because it kind of becomes messy and
distorted but that's the point
it takes the 120 degree rotation to come
back
where it started that is part of the
symmetry we can also rotate backwards so
we can do our - I'm not going to clutter
it up again but that's a
counterclockwise rotation by 120 degrees
so that gets us to a b c and we see that
these three versions of the triangle are
labeled differently so the triangle
looks the same in every case but it
results from a non-trivial
transformation on the original triangle
so this is part of the symmetry group as
we're going to call it of the triangle
the set of transformations that we can
do the triangle that leave it invariant
now of course I could do a rotation
twice right I could do our plus twice
and that would actually get me to our -
right if I did our plus again I'm not
going to draw it here because it'll
clutter up the diagram but if I rotated
this triangle this one right here if i
rotated that by another 120 degrees I
would get this triangle over here so
these are the two rotations that I can
do but I'm not done with the triangle
because there's things there are things
I can do other than rotations right so
to see that let's make some more
triangles here okay and I'm gonna put
these triangles down here not easy to do
this but you know we're learning trying
to get better at it there you go three
more triangles and I'll it'll be clear
in a second why there's three more
triangles the point is that in addition
to rotating I could also flip the
triangle right like there's nothing that
says that I'm confined to moving in the
plane of the iPad or of the board I'm
drawing on here right I could flip
around some axis so if I flip around
this axis for example I would get a B C
whereas if I flip around this axis the
original triangle I would get C a B and
if I flipped around this axis the
original triangle I would get B a C and
you can notice that every one of these
if you look at the vertices and how
they're labeled they're all distinct
from each other
okay no two of these of these six
triangles are exactly the same when you
consider I mean all the triangles are
exactly the same no two of them result
from doing nothing to the triangle they
are all a non-trivial transformation
okay so we can label these let's call
this let's call it a flip
we have flipped around the vertical axis
it's more typical to call it a
reflection but we've already used a
letter R for rotation so let's call it a
flip let's call this F 1 let's call this
one f 2 and let's call this one F 3
there you go so I think that's it you
can check at home but I think there's
nothing else you can do to the triangle
that does not get that that gets
something different than all of these
different possibilities in fact I'm sure
of it
because in this one particular case the
triangles the one case where the set of
symmetries of the triangle the geometric
shape is just the set of permutations of
the three vertices a B and C okay that
wouldn't be true in a square or Pentagon
or whatever but it's true for the
triangle so if I just enumerated ABC ACB
etc there are six of them and they
correspond to these six versions of the
triangle okay so that is those are the
symmetries of the triangle how many of
them are there you might say well there
are five because we got the first
rotation the second rotation and the
three flips but in fact there's a sixth
because we can do nothing we can just
transform the triangle onto itself
that's an important thing we can do
namely you just leave it as it was so I
will label that by the fancy number one
here the identity operation leave the
triangle invariant so I really have six
things I can do to the triangle if I
include doing nothing as as a thing that
I could do so what there's a lot of
information here there's a lot of
structure going on here this is what
makes mathematicians excited about
symmetries is that you don't need to
simply go ahead and and enumerate all
the different possible symmetry
transformations you can talk about how
they relate to each other and what kind
of structure they form so together these
six transformations
and we'll list them the identity
rotation clockwise by 120 rotation
counterclockwise 520 flip around one
axis flip around the other flip around
the third these three form a group that
is what the technical definition of the
technical term that we attach to this
kind of mathematical beast is if a group
is a little bit more specific than just
say a set it's not just a collection of
things a group forms some very specific
properties the crucial feature of being
a group is that you can take these
transformations and combine them and you
will always get something that is
another transformation that is already
in the group okay this is called the
closure property of the group the fact
that you can bind transformations you
never leave the set of operations so
let's see that in action a little bit
consider if we start up here the
original triangle and we do flip one so
we go around the vertical axis so we get
down to here I claim that I can get to
flip two by then doing a rotation so if
I go over here what do I need to do I
need to get starting from here to get to
here I need to move a down to the left
see up to the bottom right it looks like
I'm going counterclockwise which is in
fact the rotation - R - that is what we
called it so what this means and
equations is you'd write this as f -
equals R minus F 1 ok so the order
matters here as we will see in a second
so you read from right to left
first do F 1 then do R plus or minus why
why do you why do we do it in that order
well because you're supposed to be
thinking of these things not as numbers
that you're multiplying but as
operations that you're performing on the
triangle so when we do something like
let's just do an example F 1 acting on
the triangle here's a triangle that we
start with with a b c that is flipping
around the vertical axis and so that
gets us a oops a and here's the triangle
and then we get B and C okay so the
reason we read from right to left when
we transform when we combine these
transformations together is because
we're imagining them acting in turn on
the triangle itself and the one on the
rightmost is the one that acts first and
then after that go leftward let me erase
all this stuff is just going to get in
the way but that's why we go from right
to left okay so when you you can check
at home whenever you combine two these
transformations you stay inside the
group that's a crucial property of being
what it means to be a group the other
crucial properties are there's an
identity element okay there's one
element that doesn't do anything at all
and the other one is that there's always
an inverse to any operation so there's
always one operation that can be undone
by a single element of the group so for
example here we would say that our plus
is the inverse of our - okay it's our
minus to the minus one another way of
writing exactly the same thing is that
our plus times our - equals the identity
element or one [ __ ] our mine is followed
by our plus we get you back to where you
started and you can check if that's true
it is true okay what is not necessarily
true I'm sorry there's another technical
thing about associativity how you put
parentheses around your group
transformations does not matter this is
what it means to be a group but group is
a little bit more elaborate than a set
this is the kind of thing that magicians
do they start with a set of things and
they put structure on them and they say
that structure obeys different
conditions the structure here is the way
to combine the transformations together
it's the multiplication rule if you like
that multiplication rule need not be
what we call communitive the commutative
means you can change the order of
operations and it doesn't matter so here
it clearly does matter if we took not f1
followed by our - but our - followed by
f1 okay well that would start us here
the original triangle we go our - brings
us here flipping by f1 means that we
flip around the vertical axis so we
would flip a
with see so we get BCA which is not down
there it's over here
right so that equals f3 look at that so
R minus f1 does not equal F 1 R - they
do not commute and the lingo we don't
need to really know it I mean I need to
know it commutativity commuting groups
if things commute if the order doesn't
matter sometimes that's true are called
abelian groups after professor Abel and
guess what non commuting groups equals
are called
non abelian so you can see why
mathematicians would fall in love with
this you have it this beautiful
structure they fit together you can
define things you can ask questions like
do the different transformations commute
or not and so forth so this is the whole
subject of group theory and it is the
sort of mathematical version of what
physicists call symmetry transformations
is a fact of the world that we have
symmetries in the world and is a
mathematical fact that the way of
describing them is by talking about
groups now there's just a couple other
things I can't resist telling you
because this is an infinitely
interesting subject remember the point
of the group is that different
transformations complying together will
always give you another group element ok
so we can have subgroups we can have
subsets of the original group which are
themselves groups so for example if you
have the identity element and the two
rotations are plus + or minus they form
a subgroup so that's the subgroup of
these the top 3 things right here if you
rotate and rotate backwards you're never
gonna flip a flip is a whole separate
thing ok so this is a perfectly good
subgroup if you combine our + and our -
you will get each other in fact there's
a what you would do if you were being
very careful about this is you would
write out the multiplication table so we
already said that r + x our - is just
the identity but you would also write
out things like r + squared
which is guess what our - as you can go
back and figure it out okay
I'm gonna erase that because not done
writing down subgroups but that's the
kind of thing you would do so this is a
subgroup good but what about just the
identity and our plus that is not a
subgroup I'm going to make this red okay
big red X they're not a subgroup because
our plus x itself is not in that
collection of things it gives you our -
there you go
likewise if you have just the identity
and one of the flips pick any one f1 f2
f3 is this a subgroup okay well you can
go back and look I could start here in
the original triangle I could flip it by
f1 if I flip it again I just get back to
where I started so indeed this is a
perfectly good subgroup f1 squared
because f1 squared equals the identity
that's all you really need to know
whereas if you try to complicate your
life what if you said one f1 and f2 okay
so you have two different flips what is
where does that get you well so you
start here here is F here's nothing
here's f1 I flipped around the vertical
axis if I do f2 that's gonna flip around
the axis going this way so it's gonna
flip a and B so I'm gonna get B at the
top a at the bottom left C at the bottom
right which gets me here which is the
arm - element which is not in the group
that I just wrote down so this is not a
good subgroup so you can see how there's
sort of an interesting set of
possibilities what is a subgroup what is
not a subgroup one last little fact you
can talk about take two non-trivial
group elements say R + + f1 it turns out
that all six of the elements in the
group can be written as some combination
of these two so these are called the
generators it's a choice of what the
generators are there's other choices the
generators of the group transformation
from these you can build up
the entire group okay I mean I can go on
there's other things we can say about
all these things but you see why groups
are so important groups are the way to
mathematically represent the idea of
symmetry transformations okay just to be
one-one fact I really should tell you
here what a these groups all have names
okay and I kind of don't want to like
dwell on the names this group is called
d3 the dihedral group of an object with
three corners so as you might guess
there's something called d4 which is the
symmetry group of the square d5 which is
the symmetry group of the pentagon etc
and this happens to equal s 3 which is
the permutation group of three elements
ABC right so ACB BAC etc are all
different symmetry transformations of
those three elements in general as we
said the dihedral group is not going to
be equal to the symmetric group on n
elements because you have a Pentagon
you're not gonna be able to do all the
different permutations of its vertices
those are just the words who cares what
the words are what the symbols are with
the notation is what we care about is
the essence of it but when it comes to
these little examples there is another
couple of examples where knowing the
terminology will help so there's a group
called the integers actually it's not
called the integers let me let's let's
be careful
z this fancy Z is how we denote the
integers and it equals you know dot dot
minus 1 0 1 2 okay
you know what the integers are when I
say the integers are group what's going
on there it means I can add them
together if I take 0 plus 1 I get 1 if I
take 1 plus 2 I get 3 etc so if I think
of the integers as a shift of a real
line so let's imagine that I have some
real line I literally take the integers
or any set of points equally spaced and
I call each element of the integers a
shift by that much
that is a symmetry transformation on
this set of points ok but notice that I
do in fact
fulfill all the requirements the
integers if I take any two integers and
add
I get a third integer there is something
called the inverse of any integer namely
- that integer and there's also my
identity elements at number zero okay
but we we are we have baggage about the
integers we think that not only can we
add them but we can also multiply them
two times three equals six okay
so you might say well maybe there's
another thing I can do a different kind
of transformation in the integers that I
could do to make a group namely
multiplying them not dividing them or
not adding them false that doesn't work
I'll give you three seconds to think
about why it doesn't work it doesn't
work because you need an inverse to
define a group so if I have you know
plus one as my transformation then I
have minus one is my inverse
transformation whereas if I do
multiplication I can multiply by zero
and I can't undo that if I take an
integer like six and then multiply it by
0 I get 0 and there's no way to multiply
anything by zero to get back to six so
it's the integers under addition that
are a group not the integers under
multiplication so when we say in this
kind of context just the integers we
very well we generally mean under
addition the integers have an infinite
number of elements in the group there
are infinite number groups and there's
also finite number of groups like this
group up here the triangle group or the
dihedral group has six elements the
integers have an infinite number but
there's a version of the integers only
as a finite number namely the integers
modulo n and what that means is we
define Zn we define addition on the
integers but only up to n so if you get
above n whatever n is you pick it so
there's Z - there's Z 3 Z 4 different
versions of this group you just say you
know 1 plus 1 equals 2 but if you're
doing addition modulo 2 you say the 2 is
the same as 0 okay so Zn is just the set
0 1 2 dot n minus 1 once you get up to n
you wrap back around so
Zn is very much like a circle let's make
it a circle where you've written n
points okay so this is Z six and there's
an element there's another element etc
okay you come back to where you started
so these groups here this one is
isomorphic the same as Z three whereas
this group here is the same as Z two
okay so these are abelian groups if you
notice I can you know that doesn't
matter what order I do our plus or a
minus in doesn't matter if I only have
two elements in the group it better be a
billion there's no way they could not
commute with each other but so these are
two very very important discrete groups
okay discrete sets of transformations
now you notice there are an infinite
number of different groups called the
integers modulo and one for every single
value of N greater than 2 or 2 or 2 or
greater every single integer so you
could have Z a billion or whatever as in
terms of finite groups it turns out
there classifiable there's only a finite
number of ways to be a finite group
there an infinite number of finite
groups like Zn but there's that this is
only one way to be a finite group and
there's only a finite number of ways and
it was only like in 2004 they finally
classified this there's both these
continuous families of finite groups and
there's also what are called these four
addict groups there's some weird ones
there's something called the monster
group which has something like 10 to the
53 different elements and so of course
mathematicians just love this stuff
physicists like the integers and and the
integers modulo n as groups they like
the dihedral group or the symmetry group
of the sphere the of the triangle but
what they love are continuous groups ok
so that's where physics becomes really
exciting continuous groups are just what
they sound like they're groups where
there is some continuous transformation
a transformation that is that is indexed
if you want by a real number or by some
smooth parameters and continuous
parameter not buying into integer or
just some number
continuous groups also called lis groups
after professor Li who studied them
classified the earliest ones okay what's
an example of a continuous group well
remember we have the circle right
remember we have ups that's not a very
good circle there can I fix it is it
fixable yes look at that kind of like a
circle now a circle you can just rotate
by any angle right any angle between 0
and 360 degrees or we're gonna have to
update our units here sorry about that
but we're gonna have to go to radians
instead of degrees so I'm gonna have to
teach about radians if you don't already
know radians is just degrees times 2 PI
over 360 so a right angle equals PI over
2 radians all the way around the circle
is 2 pi radians although this will
become clear why this is important in a
second it's just units just a choice of
units okay but physicists mathematicians
are always going to be using radians
rather than degrees I've been shielding
you from that to some extent but now
we're gonna have to go there so anyway
any rotation of the circle by between 0
and 2pi radians is a symmetry
transformation so there's a continuous
group an infinite number of different
possible angles by which you can do that
rotation and in fact to some extent the
basic most importantly groups are in
fact generalizations of this idea of a
rotation group ok in particle physics as
we'll get to in a second we have SU 3
cross su 2 cross u 1 in the standard
model yeah and these are all examples of
continuous groups that are sort of
generalized rotations in some sense so
let's do this a little bit more
systematically let's look at that
continuous group which is called the
symmetry group of the sphere funny sorry
of the circle circle is of course a
sphere is a 1 sphere it's a one
dimensional sphere but I will call it
the circle so what are the symmetries of
the circle
well very similar to the analysis for
the triangle any rotation what we have
the identity we have any rotation by any
angle theta with theta being an element
of 0 to 2pi oops so including 0 not
including 2 pi because you can't include
2 pi ik is already there for 0 ok in
fact we shouldn't even clued the
identity element because that any
element is there but it's a rotation by
0 ok that's what it is
and there's another one there's another
can you guess what that is yes you can a
flip around some axis so you can write
some access and you can imagine just
flipping antipodal points points on
opposite sides ok we kind of talked if
we kind of implied the existence of
something like this transformation when
we did the identification of antipodal
points in the lord topology discussion
last time so together these are called
o2 that is the letter O not the number 0
2 for a two-dimensional plane where the
circle is living and oh for orthogonal
this is the orthogonal group or a thug's
and mole and in general o n is the set
of rotations oof
once again a bad handwriting day sorry
about that rotations and reflections in
n dimensions so the circle is a
one-dimensional object itself but if I
erase this bit inside here just to make
my life easier the symmetries of the
circle are the same as the symmetries of
rotations around a point in the plane so
the point the plane itself is
two-dimensional right it has two
dimensional vector space you rotate
around the center that is the orthogonal
group in two dimensions ok so in this
case and in fact in every case what's
gonna happen is oh and
the entire set of symmetries of this
n-dimensional space
the generalization of a rotation is
going to be rotations so sorry let me
just be a little bit more explicit about
it it's going to be something which we
call the special orthogonal group so
this is just rotations times z2
reflections or flips this is always
going to be true so just like the
triangle you could separate out the
rotations and the flips you can just do
that in general in any number of
dimensions for an orthogonal orthogonal
group for the continuous symmetry group
in n dimensions so generally that's what
we do we don't usually talk about Oh n
we could but the point is once you get
to the math of it and the physics of it
if you can separate out a group into two
different kinds of things and then
combine them together later on that is
almost always a sensible thing to do
there will be things that are invariant
under just s Oh N and not oops that's z2
sorry sorry it's just a two element
group not an infinite number anyway
there will be things not necessarily
this plane but there will be things that
are invariant under s o n but not the z2
flips so whenever you can sort of
separate out these groups into separate
pieces that's different kinds of
transformations that's generally a good
thing to do
okay so then this generalizes right we
have for example so3 or rotations in
three dimensions it's not a
generalization this is an example in the
3d so think of you know a three
dimensional space parametrized by three
vectors and you can rotate it you can
rotate it to be wherever you want right
so if this was if we started with
Basie's X Y Z and you rotate and you get
something X Prime
why prime Z Prime and every single
possible way to rotate that is an
element of so3 so even though there's an
infinite number of such rotations what
you can do now is not talk about the
number of transformations but the
dimensionality of the space of
transformations so oh - let's think
about it let's see let's see if you can
guess so2 is the rotations in the plane
okay this is so2 how many dimensions
knot is the thing we're rotating but is
the group how many dimensions is the
group so2
well the answer is it's just one
dimensional there's only one thing we
can do
so we're rotating two dimensions into
each other but there's only one way to
do it and therefore so2 is a one
dimensional group okay in fact the group
itself is just the circle topologically
so3 it turns out there are three ways to
do it and basically you can think about
that as you can rotate around this axis
around that axis or around that axis so
this is a three dimensional group and
that sometimes confuses people into
thinking that somehow the number of
rotations should equal the number of
ways you can the number of dimensions in
the thing you're rotating but that's not
the case so if you have s o n that is
rotations in n-dimensional space but the
dimensionality of s om works out to be
one-half n n minus one okay so if you
plug in three you're gonna get back to
where you started right one-half times
three times two is three but if you plug
in four 1/2 times four times three is
six so 4 does not equal six in general
once you get beyond three-dimensional
space the number of rotations is bigger
than the number of dimensions you're
rotating you might wonder how that can
possibly be true isn't it always true
that you just be able to rotate around
an axis but that's not true this is just
because your ability to visualize in
dimensions greater than three is failing
you when you rotate in four dimensions
you don't rotate around an axis you
rotate around a plane so a rotation
moves one axis into the other leaving
all the other axes invariant so that's
the question you should be asking
yourself how many different ways how
many different ways are there to leave
all the other axes invariant and the
answer is this so all that is just to
say s o n the group of rotations and n
dimensions is not n dimensional it is a
bigger number of dimensions ok now I'm
going to complicate your life a little
bit ok the the rotations is a pretty
obvious thing it is a non abelian group
you know other than so2 where it's just
rotating in the circle once you start
rotating in three dimensions the order
matters if you rotate a little bit
around z-axis and then a little bit
around the x axis you can convince
yourself you're gonna end up with a
different orientation than if you rotate
a little bit around the x axis and then
a little bit around the z axis it's a
non abelian group most groups are not
commutative or not abelian also in
physics many things turn out to be
complex numbers right we don't use real
numbers all the time we sometimes use
complex numbers and vector spaces can be
either real by which we mean we take
basis vectors and take linear
combinations of them with real numbered
coefficients or they can be complex and
there's other alternatives also but they
can certainly be complex let's put it
that way which means that our vectors
are sets of combinations of basis
vectors but the coefficients of those
basis vectors are complex numbers not
just real numbers so there's the version
of rotation groups that applies to
complex vector spaces and we call those
unitary groups for reasons which I'm not
gonna reveal so the unitary groups um
are symmetries of complex and
dimensional spaces just like oh n were
the symmetries of real and dimensional
spaces UN are the symmetries of complex
and dimensional spaces so just to be a
little bit more explicit about that
vector stuff I just said you know a real
vector means you might have seen things
like this you have a vector and you'd
say you know a times the unit vector in
the X Direction plus B times unit vector
in the Y direction if you're two
dimensions if you're in three then you
might have C times Z and implicitly a B
and C are all real numbers okay let me
just I don't need to be quite that
Matthew I just said the correct thing
but you don't need to be Matthew unless
it is necessary right so a B and C are
real there you go whereas in a complex
vector space
same exact notation okay V equals a and
because I don't want because space the
three-dimensional space we live in is a
real vector space okay we locate where
we are using real numbers not complex
numbers I hope you've noticed this in
your life so I'm not gonna write x y&z
let me just write some generic unit
vector e1 plus be e 2 plus C III or plus
e 4 plus C 5 you can have any number of
dimensions in your vector space you like
where a B and C are complex and of
course a complex number ie
there's a real part plus I times an
imaginary part where I equals the square
root of -1 okay and I've been careful
here you know when we did oh and versus
s oh and oh and are all the symmetries
of the n-dimensional vector space s Oh n
is just the ones that do not change the
orientation do not flip around some axis
okay you might think that since this is
the same set up but with complex numbers
rather than real numbers it's the same
thing you might think that UN is just su
n a special unitary group
and dimensions plus flips of orientation
and in fact you already know there's
something called su 3 and there's
something called su 2 so you're waiting
for me to say su n is just u n plus some
flips but that turns out not to be true
and the reason why is because if you if
you think about what is a
one-dimensional group sorry what are the
transformations of a one dimensional
vector space okay
1d space well let's look at real 1d
space that's just the number line okay
it's just the real numbers there's zero
at the middle what can you do to it
well you can translate it but we're not
counting those okay you by translate I
mean you literally shift over
that's certainly absolutely something
you're allowed to do but we're looking
at rotations or the the generalization
of rotations in 1d space and there's the
only thing you can do in a
one-dimensional space to rotate it is
actually to flip it right is actually to
exchange points on opposite sides with
the same valve now is it pretty bad I
can do better to exchange points on
opposite sides with the same value so
you know if this is minus two plus two
they get flipped back and forth that is
something you can do that's all you can
do so that is in fact oh one if you want
and that's just Z 2 it's just a group
with two elements either you don't do
something or you flip it so many
possibilities but what about 1d complex
space the complex numbers right
well one complex number is kind of like
two real numbers right you have the real
part and you have the imaginary part and
any complex number call it Omega it can
be written as the real part plus the
imaginary part or it can also be written
as the length which we can call are
times some angle theta e to the I theta
so R is the length and theta is the
angle in the complex
plain so in other words when if you
write Omega as let's say a plus IB okay
so a is this real part B is this
imaginary part you can write that
equally well as are times e to the I
theta now E I gotta do a little bit of
math here sorry about that
e is the Euler constant 2.718 dot that
the Euler constant it's special for many
reasons it's a special number in
mathematics it's an infinite number
there's no simple way to write it down
using a finite number of digits there's
no way to write it down using a finite
number of digits it has the wonderful
feature that I was tell you this and
then I'll erase it there's a function e
to the X okay this particular number
raised to the power X I can take the
derivative of that function with respect
to X ask what is the slope of that
function if I think that function looks
like it's exponential growth right
exponential growth something we all know
about these days e to the X versus X it
turns out that this is the unique
function other than just zero everywhere
with the property that its derivative is
equal to itself if it were 2 to the X or
10 to the X it would not quite have that
property that that's another little pre
factor out there so e is a very special
number good letting you letting you in
on that and even better when you raise
it to an imaginary number that's what
we're doing here e to the I theta so e
to the I theta theta is a real number
theta is just this angle here e to the I
theta equals the cosine of theta plus I
times the loop s-- don't need that I
times the sine of theta and here in
order for this formula to be true theta
has to be measured in radians okay in
going from 0 to 2 pi so if you plot
let's see if I can do this probably not
do this in real time if you plot the
cosine of theta it looks something like
this whereas if you plot the sine of
theta it would look something like this
okay that's sine theta and this is
cosine theta so again this formula
happens to work out it's a miraculous
wonderful formula that is true if theta
is measured in radians so it repeats at
theta equals two pi this is theta equals
zero right there and why is it so
interesting well remember when we did
complex numbers squared so when you have
a complex number and you take it square
what you really do is you take its
complex conjugate and then you multiply
it so by itself so e to the I theta
squared equals the complex conjugate
let's see how we can write this e to the
I theta star times e to the I theta e to
the I theta star I mean the complex
conjugate just says change all the I's
to - sighs so this is e to the minus I
theta times e to the I theta which
equals e to the minus I theta plus I
theta which equals e to the 0 which
equals 1 so that's why this is such a
nice little thing this formula e to the
I theta gives us a vector in the complex
plane of unit length okay that's why
it's convenient to write any complex
number as a length R times what we call
the phase or the angle e to the I theta
why am i doing this why am I going
through all this effort well we said up
here in one dimensional space the
orthogonal group in one dimensional
space is just flips it's just z2 it's
either you flip it or you don't those
are the only two things to do in one
dimensional complex space you have
really two dimensions to work with
there's another thing you can do you can
rotate okay so the group u1 is actually
a multiplication of a complex number
by e to the I theta so if you have some
complex number so here's the real part
here's the imaginary part and here is
the complex number call it Omega okay if
you multiply by theta
it keeps the length by e to the I theta
it keeps the length constant let's zoom
in here the length stays the same but
you rotate by an amount given by theta
so this is Omega
this is e to the I theta times Omega so
the set of all rotations in the complex
plane is multiplications by e to the I
theta because even though I 2 pi equals
1 right we can write that we did that e
to the 0 equals 1 that's also e to the 2
pi I because you go back to where you
started by that little picture up there
so anyway the point being that in the
orthogonal group case in the real vector
space case oh n is som just rotations
plus flips whereas that's not quite true
in the unitary group case UN in general
is su n which are just generalized
rotations as we expected
times u 1 which is multiplication by a
phase so multiplication by e to the I
theta and this is just called the phase
so anyway all this is to get to the fact
that this is a general rule
ok it's not the same quite the same
thing as the orthogonal group case
there's a continuous set of
transformations that we can take out of
U n to leave us with su n ok and s here
stands for a special which is just
there's a fancy way of saying what that
means but it means not just multiplying
by a face it means everything other than
multiplying by a phase ha ok and as
before we can calculate the
dimensionality of su n as it is not
going to be n it is in fact N squared
let me get it right yeah I was gonna say
N squared minus 1 and
correct I should just said it should
have believed myself there you go
it goes up very quickly the minus one is
basically the U 1 okay the
dimensionality of U 1 equals 1 because
it's just that one rotation so the
dimensionality of U n is going to be N
squared that's how many things you can
do to n complex numbers all right where
are we
you n this is the rotations complex
vector spaces very important because all
of the matter fields of the standard
model all of the electrons and the
quarks and neutrinos those are all
complex valued fields so the version
that we have to use to operate on them
if there's some symmetry between them
will be su n naught s ohem having said
that there is your secret fact I'm not
going to right now but so3 turns out to
be almost quite but almost the same
group as su 2 they're both three
dimensional groups we'll get in a little
bit to why they're a little bit
different not a little bit I mean not
today
someday someday down the road we'll show
you why they're different the topology
is a little bit different is the answer
but the basic set of transformations
looks very very similar both
three-dimensional groups
okay good so what I wanted to get to is
the fact that these UN's or su ends
really these this su n the real rotation
here this is where we get the su 2 cos
su 3 of the standard model the U one is
another symmetry of the standard model
and these are give us all the forces of
nature roughly speaking the U one is
going to give us electromagnetism the
electromagnetism earth is a reflection
of an underlying u 1 symmetry of the
complex valued electron field and
positron field the su 2 gets us the weak
interactions the su 3 gets us the strong
interactions don't have time to do any
of that today
also there's other secrets that will be
revealed but don't worry
I predict that next week we will get to
exactly that so I mostly wanted to get
to you the idea of a group and also the
specific groups that we'll be dealing
with z ZN s o n &
you and these are our biggest most
famous groups I can't however leave you
without one more fact about symmetries
it is indeed the first fact about
symmetries that many people know in
physics which is the connection between
symmetries and conservation laws
conservation was the very first topic
the very first idea that we had in this
series so it's nice to see the old
friends coming back and this
relationship is summarized in nerds
theorem I mean earther famous
mathematician of early twentieth century
and she said basically well it's a
one-way street let's put it this way
symmetries imply the existence of
conservation laws it's more subtle than
that most conservation laws in nature do
come from symmetries there's a few tiny
exceptions but typically if you find a
conservation law you should search for
the symmetry underlying it there are
subtleties dealing with what kind of
symmetry it is again there's a nervous
first theorem and second theorem we're
not going to any of those things the
basic point is that this that when you
have a symmetry there is a conserved
quantity and it turns out to be hard to
explain why actually Richard Fineman
came up with what is probably the most
transparent explanation of why northers
theorem is true which I'll try to
reproduce at least a little bit casually
here it all relies on the action
principle remember the action principle
of least action says that there's this
thing that you can calculate by
integrating over time something called
the Lagrangian and the Lagrangian
depends on the position of some let's
just say a single particle let's make
our life easy it could be fields right
and we'll be but make our lives easy
single particle as a position and a
velocity and it could also depend on
time but let's say it doesn't okay so
this is the action this is the
Lagrangian in field theory we would also
write the Lagrangian as an integral over
space
the lagrangean city okay we can do that
and the point is that if you consider
all the possible pads the particle or
the fields could take what you would
find is the actual physical path that
obeys the equations of motion minimizes
or at least extreme eise's the action
okay so it's like kind of like not
exactly like but kind of like if you
considered all the trajectories of your
system and you plotted the action it
turns out that the action would be a
minimum at the actual physical
trajectory so this is all possible
trajectories like a particle sitting
there without any forces acting on it
but just moving around in all sorts of
directions violating Newton's laws
that's a possible trajectory that we can
contemplate that conceivable maybe a
conceivable trajectory would be better
the physical ones are the ones that
actually obey the laws of physics okay
so nervous theorem says that if you have
a physical system that is described by
an action like this and by the way not
all systems are but that's what we're
gonna consider right now most systems in
quantum field theory anyway certainly
are so what it says is let's imagine a
symmetry is described by some shift of
all the values so we have X of T the
position as a function of time and V of
T the velocity is a function of time and
you shift it to something parametrized
by a parameter let's call it Epsilon
okay so to some new value X sub epsilon
of T and V sub epsilon of T so what
you're saying is you know let's say that
you are in a world where rotational
invariance is obeyed okay you see we're
in outer space the earth does not below
you you can rotate your coordinate
system however you want and the shift
might be I just changed my coordinates
by rotating a little bit or in quantum
chromodynamics the theory of the strong
interactions QCD maybe you change red
quarks into blue quarks by a little bit
and this parameter epsilon tells you how
much you change and you're gonna say
well if it's like SU three
I had many different transformations I
can do yes that's true
what we're saying here is pick one okay
and move it in one direction by an
amount Epsilon so what here is fineman's
argument for doing this for deriving
nervous theorem so here again we have
trajectories space and here now we have
time
so the actual physical trajectory may be
looks like this there you go this is X
of T and from that you could get V of T
okay and call this point a where you
begin at Point a before B where you
finish and he says okay now let's
imagine doing this transformation so I
shift by Epsilon okay to Point C right
there and then I do the same kind of
trajectory but I've shifted everything
by Epsilon shifted everything by some
amount by some transformation rotation
translation some sort of internal
rotation whatever it is okay and I will
label this point D okay so here's what
here's the argument there's a bunch of
things you can sort of say about this
picture let me move over the picture so
I can say things about it okay one is
one is that the original action s of a
going to be let's just write it as a P
okay the original path this path right
here that's some value and it better be
equal to the action of the path going
from C to D because that path is just
related to the original one by asymmetry
that is the assumption that we're making
there's a symmetry relating these two
paths okay but at another fact the D
that's the sort of the obvious fact
there's another fact that is a little
bit more subtle but look we're saying
here that the action is minimized on the
real path which means if you do an
infinitesimal
by little tiny bit of epsilon then the
action won't change okay so the total
action on a path that is displaced from
the original one by just a little bit is
equal to the action of the original path
to the two first order to the smallest
approximation okay
this is why it's subtle this way it
doesn't sound completely kosher but you
can make it completely kosher trust me
on this so what that means is if this if
this little displacement epsilon is
infinitesimal then the action associated
with a b is also equal to the action
associated with a c d b that is to say
think of this little v as an actual
trajectory you'll be moving faster than
the speed of light or something like
that but that's okay it's just a
conceivable trajectory think of the
trajectory is going from a moving over
to C on that trajectory then following
the physical trajectory up to D then
going backward okay because that is only
an infinitesimal change away from the
original one the action will be the same
again to a good approximation and you
can make it all rigorous if you want to
therefore what we can say is it had
better be the case that the action going
from A to C that little tiny trajectory
better be equal to minus the action of
going from D to B just from what we said
you know we didn't say that the action
on this path was zero going from A to C
we didn't need to say that was zero we
just need to say that when you go a to C
then up to D then back to B the whole
thing had to equal the original action
so there's a more general way for that
to be true maybe it's zero but it can be
some nonzero value as long as it's
compensated for when we go back from D
to B finally if you look at what the
formula for the action it here is it's
an integral over time okay so going from
D to B is the opposite in time of going
from B to D going the opposite direction
so si C equals minus s DP
that means it equals plus s BD if you
had gone in this direction you would get
the same answer you get sorry you would
get minus what you got by going from D
to B so look what we found
look at that this is kind of fun si see
the action along this little path right
here is equal to SB D the action of that
little path right there and indeed it
didn't matter where we picked our
original or or stopping points all of
these little paths if you calculate the
action on them you would get the same
answer the quantity would be the same so
we say therefore s a si or its
generalizations later in time is
conserved it's the same at every moment
in time so the action along the path
that you get from wherever you are and
going by this amount by an infinitesimal
shift gives you a conserved quantity
okay
that's nervous Theorem the existence of
a symmetry gives you a conserved
quantity it's sort of not at all
surprising in some sense what a symmetry
says is that there's a direction in the
space of all possible things that can
happen where it doesn't matter right you
can shift in this direction it doesn't
matter doesn't matter where you do your
experiment how you set up your
orientation of your axes or anything
like that so the fact that it doesn't
matter sort of morally corresponds to
the fact that some number is constant it
would not change if you did shift in
that particular direction this is just
the formalization of that so that's
nervous theorem so it turns out this is
kind of a big deal so for example
spacetime symmetries we have so
translations translations are that's a
terrible way of spelling translations
I'm just go start from scratch
translations are just shifts right
shifts in either space or time
translations in space give rise to
observe conserved quantity called
momentum
makes sense how many ways are there do a
translation in space
well there's XY and Z there are three of
them and there are three components of
momentum that works translations in time
well how many of them are there for that
there's only one and guess what there's
one conserved quantity we call it the
energy rotations how many of them are
those well we have three axes in space
they're all real right so the number of
transformations is so3 the
dimensionality of so3 is three so there
are three conserved quantities and we
call those angular momentum and then we
can go on to the internal symmetries
like the u 1 symmetry that I told you we
haven't really talked about in detail
yet but we will of electromagnetism is
what gives rise to electric charge being
conserved and so forth so this fact that
norther discovered near this theorem
right there which is that this quantity
is conserved is not just a mathematical
curiosity it's crucially important in
all of physics it gives rise to things
that we care about like energy
conservation charge conservation stuff
like that
ok that's all I wanted to say about
symmetry what we're gonna need to do in
the next video the next idea is get some
payoff oK we've done two videos in a row
on math math is great but we're trying
to understand the physical universe so
next time geometry and symmetry are
going to come together to tell us
something about the fundamental laws of
nature